Yep.
To sort of separate,
you were talking about being around 300
million people,
so why is,
why is a group of similar size,
which is America,
it really face.
You think the right and left can talk to
each other.
Do you think they speak the same
language?
Right?
You see it that fragmenting occurring
and they really are.
Not only are they speaking different
languages,
they're speaking different languages.
It's the right way of thinking about it.
Yes,
it's very,
very dangerous.
You know,
I think the US worked for a long time,
first of all because it didn't always
have 300 million people.
It's a lot of people to put under one
umbrella.
Now the utility of the American system
is that it is a hierarchy,
right?
There's individuals,
families,
towns,
states underneath a somewhat loose
federal structure and that sort of.
So it's not a,
it's not a monolith where everyone has
to speak precisely the same language.
It's got some flexibility built into its
structure because it's,
it's,
it's formulated into components which
have a certain amount of autonomy and so
far that's worked sufficiently well.
Whether it will and it'll probably
continue to work.
The Americans are a very,
very robust people and they've gone
through things that are analogous to
what they're going through now.
Many times God only knows,
right?
But,
but it's very dangerous thing to presume
that the Americans are down for the
count because they have an uncanny
ability to rise from the ashes even
stronger than they were before.
But you can certainly see the danger
lurking in Europe.
That's,
that's a different thing.
Like I think the European state is
doomed because I think it grew too fast
and it's severed that connection between
like there's not the proper hierarchy
of,
of identification.
So.
And people are saying,
wait,
right Brussels,
like who the hell are you guys?
Why are you making decisions for us?
And we don't agree with your decisions.
And like are you sure that Greece and
Germany can be in the same place?
Because that's by no means self evident.
Right.
The Germans aren't very happy about it
and the Greeks aren't very happy about
it.
And one of the rules for making an
organization is that it's a lot easier
to make a functional organization worse
than it is to make a dysfunctional
organization better.
And so you might say,
well,
you've got Germany and France and
England while let's say Germany and
France powerhouses,
especially Germany,
they can afford to bring Greece in.
Well maybe,
but there's no evidence that they can
afford it.
So I mean,
Greece is unbelievably corrupt.
No one pays her income tax.
That's a big problem,
right?
And bringing them in to a union at a
high order has no effect whatsoever on
the micro behaviors.
And the thing is the micro behaviors
have to be rectified and no one really
knows how to do that.
How do you stop a country where people
don't pay their taxes from?
How do you stop the people from not
paying their taxes?
Why do we pay our taxes?
Who knows?
We could just all of a sudden decide not
to.
The government wouldn't have the
resources to run around gathering them
all up for one reason or another.
It's become customary for people in
functional Western democracies to pay
their taxes,
but why,
who knows?
It would have been way easier for us
just to do what the Greeks did and
pretend to pay them,
you know,
so there are too big I think.
And so the people on the right is saying
back to the nation and like I understand
why they're doing that,
but,
but the danger is the nation will
subordinate the individual and I do see
it as another example of safe spaces.
It's just scales different.
So.
And that's why I think that the proper
antidote to that,
to both the chaos on the left and the
order on the right roughly speaking,
is to walk the proper line in the
middle.
I wouldn't,
we better do that because things are not
things that are too chaotic at the
moment.
So it's not good.
Maybe it's really good that's possible.
But we're in a state where I really
believe we're in a state where things
could go any number of ways and there's
no,
there's no predicting it.
So.
And I've never felt that,
you know,
I mean,
I lived in the eighties and you know,
political correctness rose up in the
nineties as well,
and I can remember a lot of what
happened in the early seventies with the
oil crisis and all that.
So there were times when things were
shaky but they weren't shaking the way
they are now.
They're an internal shakiness rather
than something that was a threat that
was,
seemed to be imposed from the outside.
And that's different.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it is associated with,
with this intellectual war that's going
on with postmodernism in new Marxism and
all of that as well.
So.